et décryptage à présent de la situation
avec régis le sommier grand reporter
arte france
bonsoir régis merci d'être avec nous les
relations ne cesse de se dégrader entre
la france plus largement les européens
et la jante malienne comment est-ce
qu'on en est arrivé là
alors c'est un long processus
un processus qui a commencé en fait bien
largement avant le coup d'état d'août
2020 qui a amené cette junte au pouvoir
avec à sa tête le colonel waseem hugo et
à l'actuel président du mali disons que
il y a comment au mali il ya eu des
années pendant des années donc le le
défunt président puisqu'il vient mourir
comment ibrahim keita
à comment assurer la présidence
justement et n'est pas parvenu à comme
on dit à apporter une sécurité en dépit
du de l'après l'immense présence de
barkan à ses côtés la corruption s'est
généralisée dans le pays et beaucoup de
choses lui sont attribués aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que on pense que fin
beaucoup de maliens sont persuadés qu'
une partie de l'éclairage et man de leur
pays qui est devenu il faut le rappeler
un est quasiment un état failli ne
contrôlant plus des pans entiers de son
territoire et bien sont dus à cette
président seydoux le coup d'état qui a
eu lieu en août 2020 coup d'état qui est
jugé par certains maliens tout à fait
légitime mais les militaires ont été
applaudis à comment à ce moment là et
donc les forces là comment la khl à la
coalition les forces barkan comment la
france puis ses partenaires ont été
évidemment considérez-vous sans
considérer aujourd'hui de plus en plus
par les maliens comme des forces
étrangères qui occupent le pays c'est
une usure une certaine façon d'un
héritier lee qui est dû à ses huit
années de barkan et le fait que la junte
au pouvoir aussi s'autorise à aller voir
d'autres partenaires et en l'occurrence
la vraie points de tension c'est les
pourparlers qui ont eu lieu pendant ces
derniers mois avec donc la milice privée
wagner russe donc et donc de ceux de ce
point de vue là les français considèrent
comme insupportables que finalement une
aura notre notre entité militaires
puissent prendre leur place au mali
alors il ya eu aussi une sorte
d'intransigeance qui s'est établi que la
part des autorités maliennes qui
aujourd'hui refusent tout 2 ne demande à
être mis au courant de tout
mouvement de troupes et on l'a vu avec
dans le cadre de la force takouba vous
c'est qu'à force nakba c'était voilà une
manière de remplacer par cannes est
actuellement c'est la force qui remplace
barque anomalie cette force elle est
composée de forces spéciales européennes
inde et des suédois des tchèques des
français évidemment qui vont qui sont
quand même qu'ils restent l'ossature de
cette force et elle devait aussi se
composer de forces spéciales danoise les
autorités maliennes avaient donné avait
dit qu'elle étudier cette possibilité
les danois sont arrivés et le du
gouvernement malien a demandé au
danemark de retirer ses troupes et le
danemark a dû obtempérer donc là c'est
véritablement un camouflet pour la force
tac pas parce que c'est sans forces
spéciales comme en plus qui sont retirés
et on peut se demander puisque les
suédois ont annoncé début janvier qu'il
retirerait leurs troupes également à un
moment donné n'ont pas donné de date
précise mais quel va être l'avenir de
cette présence parce que cette présence
conditionnent tout la présence française
militaire au mali et on sait déjà que
par cannes à retirer une partie de ses
troupes en tout cas n'y a plus de
troupes françaises dans le nord du mali
et ses troupes de takouba elles sont
très importantes aussi parce que elles
sont pour la formation le voit à l'écran
là actuellement celle ce sont des
troupes qui assure la formation de
l'armée malienne à travers des petites
unités très bien entraîné donc les
partenaires de l'effort spéciale donc
forme l'armée malienne justement pour
aller comment essayer justement de
reprendre le pays une grosse difficulté
puisque encore une fois comme je le
disais au début le mali reste un pays
extrêmement morcelé extrêmement éclaté
dans lequel finalement des des zones
entières les dents sur des zones
entières l'activité s'est totalement
réduite et sur ces zones est bien le
gouvernement central n'exerce plus
d'autorité jean yves le drian l'a
déclaré ce matin la france et ses
partenaires européens ne peuvent pas
rester comme cela c'est ce qu'il a dit
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
c'est très commencer un tournant
actuellement en étant on le voit aussi
avec le coup d'état au burkina faso il
ya eu coup d'état en guinée aussi
même au niveau de ce qu'on appelle la
cedeao qui est donc la communauté des
pays d'afrique de l'ouest sur laquelle
la france a encore une influence mais on
se rend compte que un certain nombre de
cellules de ces pays le mali le burkina
la guinée par exemple non plus non
qu'ils n'hésitent pas ouvertement à
critiquer c'est un set cette instance et
à ne pas lui obéir notamment dans les
sanctions l'ue et la guinée a dit
qu'elle n'appliquerait pas les sanctions
qui ont été décidées contre le mali
récemment c'est à dire la fermeture des
échanges des autres pays avec le mali
donc il y a de plus en plus c'est
gouvernement de transition alors cédé
gouvernement de transition qui sont
censés rendre le pouvoir à un pouvoir
civil on établit un calendrier pour
s'aperçoit en tout cas pour le moment au
mali que ce calendrier n'a pas été tenu
et que ce sont toujours les militaires
au pouvoir gouvernement de transition
l'a également au tchad 1 également des
militaires qui sont au pouvoir en guinée
il ya une multiplication de ces
gouvernement de transition dirigé par
des militaires alors est ce que ça
signifie que c'est la fin de ce qu'on a
appelé globalement la françafrique c'est
à dire que la règle influence française
aujourd'hui se réduit on voit de plus en
plus de voix qui contestent donc parmi
ses dirigeants la présence et l'activité
de la france ces déploiements et le fait
que des déploiements militaires
européens soit opérée sur le sol malien
en particulier et que ben voilà tout ça
mais en question l'avenir des relations
de la france c'est c'est une période
quand même très compliqué une période
comme on peut être un tournant justement
dans les relations entre la france et
l'afrique de l'ouest en france ancienne
puissance coloniale qui conserve de l'
influence mais qui on le voit on a de
moins en moins merci beaucoup régis le
sommier pour votre décryptage résume un
seul et grand reporter et avertissent